how's your breasts my butt Oh God we're
playing agario we're playing on our own
server the service is only for fans or
only for bros so right now there's only
four people playing it's already kind of
starting to like I just tweeted out how
to join Oh
number four whoo oh there's one popping
in I'm scared of leaving the tweet up
for too long because I'm scared I will
crash the servers
I'll never third okay we're playing just
bros now haha music social what are you
doing gross what you're going to do
Roach solid fan the I - I tweeted that I
was solid fan and wonder how many people
join [ __ ] parents thanks Bruce I do
every head guy I like there's a bunch of
people in there that's [ __ ] awesome
look hahaha
you really have enough oh thank you you
really have nothing better to do all day
do you um got doubt I can't lose I got
like such a head start but there's so
few of the Salus or whatever whoever
kills me we'll get insta ban that's rule
number one by the way
killing parrots I forgot to say that
[ __ ] foot my anus what did you do my
anus
don't do it rose don't do it rose Eden
what do you do and stop nibble on my
titties Oh little bit lag I'm glad I
deleted it quickly honestly every time I
tweet something you just you bros just
come in and crash all the servers and
people get pissed off so and stop
oh [ __ ] pimp - sapota savannah come on I
don't know man come on step on up hahaha
oh there's so many people playing I
don't know if we have a limit on it I
don't how many people can join uh you
guys are [ __ ] taking over and [ __ ] I
don't like this Oh ten now your brother
to get at this game this is [ __ ]
yes awesome yes feed the salad fan
the fandom salads oh god my anus looks
horny it's awesome how many people are
in here
I'm not even top ten anymore come on let
me feast on your titties how do you guys
grow so fast
thank you thank you bless you bro I
accept all sacrifices oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] such a [ __ ] mess ah
oh crap man [ __ ] yeah ah let's say I
never seen this many people oh man thank
you thank you for Fears hahaha oh man
this is so much fun I'm so glad we got
to set up it was set up by mystery or
mqx we helped me out with the forums um
really fun stuff don't you know who I am
[ __ ]
dag [ __ ] Pierce thank you thank you
somehow God here's the lag all right
well he's still working somehow it's
very delayed right now Bonnie I'm not
controlling to go in there bog you had
one job Bruce not to kill the salad fan
look at you you're a disgrace
this Fano is number third this is so
ridiculous
oh look it's joke so tickly why is he at
his own [ __ ] avatar let's [ __ ]
[ __ ] help someone understands now
how to play this game sanic you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
god damnit ever great thick lip makeup
yes I'll feed feed parents thank you I
love salad Thank You salad thank you
thank you bless you breasts I love you
breasts thank you so much I've gotta
gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta go
team RCI's number six oh man Oh Thank
You Fran salad Thank You Brad hahahaha
feed me my job to follow what the [ __ ]
man I thought we were together Stefano's
yeah you [ __ ]
that's right you reckon [ __ ] hahahaha
yes number three go salad fan whoo
please please please I love you
don't touch the violence salad fan you
know who I am
oh you're not a fan of salad please
ah what am I so like okay I'll take it
oh my god I'm so into this game hahaha
this is [ __ ] amazing oh oh that's
right [ __ ]
that's what you get for being greedy
salad fried is number two
all hail the solid fat what the lag the
lag ah na na the legs up
Sabitha my favourite way back after all
these years
hahaha alright I left end that they're
so much fun playing with you bros thanks
to the ones who didn't eat me
and brofist to the ones who fed me and i
brofist up your butt the ones who kill
me
alright price that's always stay awesome
well it looks like you don't [ __ ] up
now then yeah hey oh god damn we're
second oh my god that's amazing
that was you [ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
Oh I'm gonna [ __ ] murder you and your
car